hundreds of millions of Americans are
getting ready for Thanksgiving it's not
just 10 days away if we can believe that
whether we like it or not inflation is
making everything so much more expensive
so the cost of a turkey is up 17 and
grocery prices overall are much higher
than that Nancy Chen found the reason
for some of the price hikes and she's
got some ideas on how you can save some
money
an hour outside of Pittsburgh
the Jones Turkey Farm has been in the
family for three generations a lot of
work goes into raising base yes
but Dave Jones has never been challenged
like this it seems like this here has
been much more difficult than ever
it tops everything
everything doubled this spring
from the feed to the fertilizer the cost
to run the farm has gone up which means
the cost for customers has two how much
did you have to raise the prices of your
turkeys 50 cents a pound this year and I
should have raised it a dollar a pound
but I at that point I figured I'd lose
too much business I'd have turkeys left
over
all this as Farmers battle one of the
worst outbreaks of avian flu which is
wiped out at least 6 million turkeys
hiking prices even further and household
items used to make some Thanksgiving
Staples are also gobbling up more money
the price of eggs is up 43 percent
butter nearly 27 percent and flour about
25 percent is this the costliest
Thanksgiving that you've seen oh without
a doubt Emily Weinstein is the food and
cooking editor of the New York Times her
tips on Curbing costs start with the
centerpiece itself turkey how do we save
money on these guys just by exactly the
size turkey you need don't buy a giant
one hoping for leftovers she says to
highlight vegetable sides over meat and
use frozen ones instead of fresh is
there a way to spread the cost here if
you've ever considered doing a
Thanksgiving potluck this is the year to
do it ask your loved ones to bring
dishes everyone will be happy to be
involved
and start shopping for non-perishables
right now retailers like Walmart are
pricing Thanksgiving Staples the same as
last year and ALDI is taking them back
to 2019. at the end of the day though I
mean choose what means the most to you
and you can cut Corners elsewhere so a
turkey sixty dollars no problem yeah
it's it's a lot of money isn't it yeah
it is and eggs up 43 that's giant yeah
my mind is still blown that Thanksgiving
is how many days away ten days ten days
are you ready no not ready you might as
well just start calling it 20 20.
exactly yep get your checkpen ready
you're right about that Nancy thank you
so much